i want to share with you how i make my
[Music]
maps
okay i know all those clips are super
fancy but i need to tell you it wasn't
always this way i used to be very
not good at making maps like look at
this first map i ever made
back in 2012. a foreign service officer
in the field
it pains me to look at that and to hear
my voice and i'm trying to sound all
cool
and casual you got to start somewhere i
guess from that time on i was 24 years
old
i poured myself into learning after
effects the software that i use to make
maps
i devour tutorials and i got better and
better at making maps
to tell the types of stories i wanted to
tell and that's what this video is it's
sort of the result
of many many years of refinement so
today what i'm going to do
talk a little bit about my journey in
map making and the evolution of my style
and then i'm going to dive into two
different workflows one is a workflow
that requires a 200
plug-in which is expensive and i used to
not be able to afford that and
so i'm also going to teach you the
workflow that doesn't
include that plug-in a workflow that i
used for years
even at vox i used it for a long time
for map making
i don't use it anymore because it's less
efficient but i want to
teach you both workflows so you have
both options and using the workflow i
use currently
i will show you how i make an animation
like this
and all of this i'm going to do on a
laptop that intel
sent me so everyone's heard of intel but
this computer that they sent me has this
evo badge on it which is their brand new
11th gen processor the major highlight
of this thing is that it is
lightning fast it provides an insane
amount of
speed and by the way there's a link in
my description that you can click to go
learn more about
the 11th gen processor and intel evo
overall
go click that link supports this channel
but also teaches you a lot more about
how this stuff works intel sent it to me
asked me to try out one of my heavy
workflows on it see how it works
and that's what i'm going to do and i'm
going to take you along on the journey
but first
story time
so after i made that first map back in
2012 the next year i graduated from
college moved to washington dc and got a
job at
a think tank where i made map stories
for them that's where i really started
to refine my map making workflow
and learn how to use maps to tell a
variety of different stories
to show data to show historical trends
to draw different types of borders
to use it as a creative tool and then in
2014 vox was born
and i got rejected from vox tried again
got accepted
and then started working there i brought
this map making workflow to vox
continue to refine it as i told all
sorts of stories eventually i started
going out into the field
and shooting sort of mini documentaries
using maps to help complement those
stories
the series after all was about borders
and i found a need to draw
really specific borders in a really
specific way to show data in a really
specific way
and so i had to upgrade my whole map
making workflow this all came to a head
in the last season of borders which was
borders india where
i had to take a bunch of physical maps
from the partition of india
and translate them into the digital
space to tell this really important
partition story
i tell you this whole story number one
because i want you to know that i wasn't
always good at maps i was once very bad
at maps and through a lot of practice
got better okay so there's some hope in
that number two
i want you to know that there's a lot of
refinement and work that has gone into
the workflow i'm about to share
so just know that this isn't something i
just sort of pulled out of my hat this
is something that i've been
polishing for years okay without further
ado
let's do this
so what's fascinating to me about this
whole thing is that
for the years that i've been developing
this workflow i
have always worked on these like big
beefy computers
the fact that i'm sitting here with this
computer that is a little bigger than a
tablet
in terms of how light it is and how
nimble it is and the 11th gen processor
gives you the power to take on this
workflow is
wild to me it is wild and it's it's sort
of proving my age here like i'm sort of
like the old person being like
back background monitor so as i promised
i'm going to show you two workflows the
one i did for many many years that
doesn't require any plugins it just
requires
after effects the adobe animation
program which is a program that is
enhanced by this processor
then i will move on to the one that
requires the 200
plugin called geo layers if you want to
just skip to that to the geo layers part
go to the time code that is here on
screen and
you can skip to it but if not let's dive
in to my original workflow one of the
cool things here
is that intel actually works with adobe
to make sure that their hardware works
most efficiently with their software so
they like collaborate
my original workflow is simple it has to
do with
two main ingredients after effects and
a file called jenkins this is a file
that i
refined for years it's an illustrator
file that has
all of the countries in the world that
are
layered out not all of them are layered
out but a lot of them are
and that is very high resolution
in that you get some really nice detail
in all of
these countries you can command a
and get all of them selected and you can
change the
stroke if you want if you want the
borders to be like a dark gray or
something you can do that
it takes a minute because well it
doesn't take a minute it
uh that was very fast this is a big file
it's got a lot of data
in it and um this is what makes this
first workflow tick
this file is free for all of my patrons
i have a bunch of people on patreon who
support me
and this is a perk that i'm putting up
right now on patreon so
if you want this file go sign up on
patreon let's talk about how this works
in after effects
i want to bring this into after effects
i'll leave it open in illustrator
i'll show you why in a minute bring it
in and it's going to ask me right away
do you want this to be
merged in as one piece of footage or do
you want to make it a composition
have all the layers editable for now i
just want footage if you were doing
something
that had a lot of different layering of
countries
and you needed to make all the countries
different colors or whatever
then you could make it a composition
because it's all layered up but for now
it's just a big piece of footage
take that big piece of footage and put
it into a new comp
we'll call it map the old way
this is my old style 1920x1080 make sure
this is like you know
like three minutes or something
and you bring it right in okay
this is vector so you can zoom in as
much as you want on this
if this little thing is clicked click
let's give this thing a background with
control
y i'm gonna make the background sort of
like a bluish thing
like that for water i don't know and now
we've got ourselves a background i'll
put it underneath
and now let's say i want to change the
color here you could do it two ways you
could do it right here in
illustrator you could select all and
change the fill but the easier way to do
it is just to take
a hue saturation and throw it on
and start playing with the hue
saturations
okay that's nice and again if i wanted
to change these borders
i could come in here control a and here
and here make these borders
all white and save this is happening way
faster than what i'm used to
um okay anyway
next we go back the file is now updated
so now i've got this thing
that i could zoom in on itself or
better yet i could make a null a layer
new null and this is going to be my
controller
i will control everything so control
okay
and i will parent this guy right here
again make sure that this has
uh this little thing so it looks like a
little sunshine
so that it stays nice and high res as we
zoom okay
next thing i'm going to take the anchor
point by holding down y
and i'm going to put it over the country
i want to
zoom into for now and i'm going to hit s
for scale and start
zooming and watch what happens i can
zoom as much as i want and boom it's
like
crystal clear so basically your
animation
p and s is a matter of now
uh go putting two little keyframes going
to where you want to go next and
going over a little bit or going this
way
and you can now animate and maybe zoom
out a little bit
okay and now you've got yourself a
little animation
okay you can do that anywhere in the map
it's very simple
it is big giant jenkins what if i want
to color in iraq
there is a very easy way to do this you
could either import
jenkins with all of the layers
as compositions and that's a different
workflow i'm not going to go into that
but it is possible because all the
layers are layered out in
uh illustrator right here you can see
um or my favorite thing to do
is to check this out control y make a
new solid and i'm gonna call it a rock
and this is the color of the thing i'm
going to highlight
i'm going to make it some orangey
something and i'm just going to put it
over the top okay
that is a rock but check it out i'm now
going to go back into
illustrator and to be safe i'm going to
hit a to get the direct select tool
which is a tool that really doesn't
select
doesn't include any of the groupings
that could be here none of this is
it's all pretty cleanly paired down but
i'm going to grab that
control c for copy back to after effects
oh i have to have this selected ctrl v
for paste
and boom that's actually rock watch what
happens
if i scale this sucker up scale it up
and now i have a mask that is a rock
super low res
not for long boom that thing makes it
nice and crystal clear
now the trick is you want to make sure
that this is
parented to the same controller so
they're all part of the same system
so now during that little move that i
did
i want this to animate on so
i'm going to take t make a keyframe
and bring it out and then start it at
zero so it goes from zero to a hundred
over time and you can see that as it
goes from left to right
it animates on okay boom
okay so that is the basics this is how i
used to do it i used to make
so many videos using this workflow
of zooming around using a null and a big
old
file and layering stuff on top of it and
there was like 50 or 100 layers
all parented to this one controller and
it was pretty nuts but then i discovered
geo layers and more importantly i could
afford shield layers it is expensive but
so incredibly useful so let's now move
on to how we would approach
this same thing with geo layers which is
really a
much more powerful workflow
so far candidly 100 like honestly the
11th gen
evo processor is killing it it's
actually kind of frustrating because i
have
like i'm used to working on these big
expensive beastly machines
and in some ways this is um outpacing
them
like that what it was doing in
illustrator with the selection stuff
it's almost like wait what i can get
over that uh keep going
really cool though really cool that this
little chip has so much power to make
these workflows like
buttery smooth uh in such a teeny little
thing so this next workflow is
geo layers i'm not going to go into how
geo layers works
fundamentally there are loads of
wonderful tutorials that geolayers
itself has put together
and you should go watch those if you're
interested in learning the fundamentals
of geo-layers you'll pick up on some of
them by seeing what i'm doing here
but i'm not going to go step by step in
this next workflow i'm going to
show you how to style a map to exactly
how you want to style it
i'm going to show you how to set it up
with geo layers and to link that styling
into jailers
to move stuff around and then to label
and do sort of what we did here with a
rock where you can draw a country
all of that is so much easier in jail
there's check it out
i'm going to make a new comp and i'm
going to call this comp
map the new way first things first we're
going to pull up geo layers i have it
all installed
i'm going to go to extensions i'm going
to go to geo layers
it's going to power up so i'm going to
hit the tilde key in the upper left
to make this full screen it just makes
it a lot easier for me to see for you to
see for everyone to see
this is blinking right now because this
is where you need to click first create
a new
map comp a map comp is basically
a map that you can style and move around
i'm going to call this one rock map
okay and it will live within the comp we
just made which was called
mapping the new way okay after hit next
it's going to
ask me what the style is you can license
some of this data
that they have on the geolayers site or
you can pick one of their default styles
or you can do what i do which is
go to mapbox mapbox
are the people behind a lot of the
mobile apps you use
the maps you use for like uber or
grubhub i don't know but like those
types of maps mapbox
makes those but hack of the world
is that you can design your own maps and
not use them for an app but use them
in geolayers check it out this is called
mapbox studio and it is
free for you to use for non-commercial
purposes
so new style come in here
and you can choose one of these
pre-baked styles that they have let's do
outdoors
the beautiful thing about this is you
can now customize it so outdoors
is really a nice looking map style
so this is just like a sort of google
maps and you can see that
as i zoom different features come on
like as i just zoomed right now
all of these interstates and their signs
came on all these labels
i don't want all these things you may
but i don't i like to clean up my map
so i'm going to go over to iraq which is
the place that we are
focusing on here and i'm going to go
simply click
on a place like baghdad and say place
labels i'm going to click it
and i'm going to say place labels i
actually don't want to see you
so countries nope states and provinces
nope
settlements nope subdivisions none of it
i'm also seeing these
provincial borders which i don't really
want to see you may want to see those i
don't so i'm going to hit
administrative boundaries disputed
country boundaries
i don't know if you want those state and
province boom that's what we don't want
okay so you can start to see the power
of this we went from a big
cluttered design to a super clean nice
design
that we can put our own labels on once
this is in geo layers
yes this is going to be in geolayers
pretty soon this is ready for me
to bring into after effects
the way i do that is first hit publish
publish
and then i'm going to get a special code
that i'm going to use in after effects
you go up to share and warning this is
gonna look like black magic what i'm
about to do because it's like so buried
in these menus
you go to share you go over to third
party
you go here to cardo and you grab this
api address copy it okay
you take this sucker over to here you
remember where we were here we had made
the map comp
and now it's asking us what kind of
style do we want we want to add a new
style
and we want to paste it into this uri
code command v paste
boom there's our map and i'm going to
hit apply
so now i've got this new map here i'm
going to actually rename it
to a outdoor map okay
i've got that big api code i'm gonna hit
apply
and here it is outdoor beautiful
and create and now it's doing its magic
and it is creating a comp that allows me
to see this map comp
but in after effects here's the deal
though
you won't see it in high res right away
at first you'll see it sort of like this
if these are temporary tiles that it
just downloads for you
to block out your animation and start
moving
eventually when you're done you'll hit
finalize and it will download all these
high-res tiles as
good as you want them so let's talk
about what is going on in here you have
two layers down here you have the map
which that's the baseline thing you're
not you're never going to animate the
position
or scale of this i'll show you what you
do animate and then you have this anchor
this anchor is the thing that you anchor
anything you want to stick on the map
you parent it to this and it will stick
and we'll get to that in a minute
but first let's just figure out how to
move around the easiest way to move
around
is just with this thing over here zoom
out
and the map comp zooms out zoom in
and the map comp zooms in drag and the
map comp drags and get ready for the
best part
right click and drag up and you get a
tilt look at that okay you're starting
to see how i make my videos now this is
like
you're probably like seeing how the the
sausage is made you're like oh that's
how he does it
so let's let's do some key frames i'm
going to start here
way back here and i'm going to zoom out
i want it to start up here and i'm going
to hit this big old
oops i'm going to hit this big old
keyframe button right here i'm going to
go forward to
you know seven seconds and i'm going to
zoom in
to iraq so i'm just going to zoom in by
scrolling okay zooms in
this isn't finalized so it'll look
better when it's finalized
let's say i want it to start wide zoom
in to a rock
wait there for a minute and then zoom in
to a little village in the south of a
rock
so i'm gonna have it wait there for
maybe i don't know four seconds
and then i am going to look at all of
these
these are the key frames that run
geo layers latitude which makes it go up
and down
longitude which makes it go left and
right zoom which makes it
zoom bearing which watch
makes it spin and pitch which makes it
go down
okay you can if you're more comfortable
down here with these you can just
keyframe everything down here instead of
using this ui
i'm gonna get rid of these so we zoom in
and i tend to always go right onto the
keyframes and make sure there's a
keyframe
everywhere it's going to sit for a
little bit and maybe during while it's
sitting
i'm going to have it pitch down just a
titch like this
okay everything else i'm gonna have sit
and now i wanted to zoom into a little
village in
in southern iraq called basra it's not a
village it's a city
it's one of the big cities in iraq i
could either go find it and try to zoom
in
but here's where jewelers becomes truly
magical
you can search on the internet for
addresses
for cities for even latitude and
longitude and in fact again you can
always
take this guy hit tilde and get the full
screen here i'm gonna hit
basra b-a-s-r-a okay
basra and there it is this is uh basra
in iraq it says it right there this is
data scraped from the internet you can
do several things here you can make a
label which we'll do in a little bit
you can fit view which means it will
take where your camera is or where
you're zoomed and it will zoom you in
to basra i'm going to hit that boom and
now watch what happens when i go back
hit tilda and i'm in basra
and because i was back here
it did all of the latitude and longitude
for me to the point where i'm now in
basra so now i have a zoom
from here all the way into basra i'm
going to put myself over those keyframes
and maybe pitch down just a little bit
maybe do this bearing a little bit and
maybe what i'll do is i'll take this
bearing and i'll bring it out a little
bit so it orbits
so this bearing is sort of coming down
and orbiting like this it's a little bit
delayed the more you delay it the more
sort of orbiting happens this is cool
this is looking really really cool
in a matter of a few minutes okay let's
say i want to
highlight a rock label it and then zoom
into basra
so first things first i am going to
try to find a shape of a rock now you
remember how we did that with
um the illustrator file and all of that
that was very clunky
and sort of handmade this is a lot
smoother so i'm going to hit back
you really it's really important that
you hit back because right now when
you're searching the internet
you're in this sort of second layer of
the interface
you want to hit back so you're back to
your home you have your search internet
up here
but then you have this hub this is like
your data hub down here again i'm going
to go
tilde to make it big your data hub is
where you can put
geo data sets which are like geojsons
that's a little advanced
if you're new to this but more
importantly
an example of a data set is a country
like
how a country's shape is you can go here
and add a feature to this data browser
and i want to download features and i
want to download countries so now it's
downloading
i now have natural earth data for every
single country
in the world what i'm going to do is i'm
going to find a rock or i can just
filter out right here iraq
boom there it is and i'm going to hit
the draw feature
which may be cut off a little bit if
your interface is a little bit you need
to sort of scroll to get to it
now if i do that you can either have an
animate on which i don't ever really use
i like to just have it drawn and then i
can animate it myself
and boom there it is what i love about
this is it comes already anchored and
like ready to roll
here it is a rock it's anchored to this
anchor null which is really important
and so now anything i do it will
go with it now let's make a label for a
rock generally you can use the label
maker in here which i'll explore
in a minute but i also just want to show
you how i do it with text
so i'm going to hit ctrl t to get my
text
i'm going to type in iraq
now remember this thing has to be
anchored to
the iraq map anchor or it won't scale
with
with us it'll just stay in the middle
like that whereas if i do this
and i bring it here everything
everything everything that you want to
stick to the map needs to be
anchored i also need to make a 3d if i
want it to respond to some of these
yeah like that okay see now it's totally
stuck to it next
let's zoom in to basra and label basra
we're going to zoom in i'll probably
want this orange to sort of fade away
while we zoom so i'm going to hit t for
transparency or opacity
and we're now in basra i could either do
the text thing that i just did
or a really cool feature is i'm going to
search basra again
b-a-s-r-a and instead of
having it fit view like i did the first
time i'm going to hit
make label or add label boom
and there it is basra
and that basra right there is responsive
so i could have it as it as we zoom out
look at that it's it scales with the map
comp
in this really cool dynamic way you can
come here there's all sorts of
things you can do here to make it react
a little bit differently
that is labeling so this next step
is the most important in terms of time
management it takes time
and in terms of making sure that your
map looks beautiful so i'm going to hit
finalize what that's going to do
is it's going to connect to the server
of that mapbox studio
profile that we made and it's going to
download little jpegs
from the internet onto this machine and
it's going to arrange them perfectly
and put expressions in them and do all
this stuff so that it looks really
natural to what we animated
it's a really magical process and it
requires
good internet or decent internet and it
requires
good processing power because it's a lot
of calculations happening at once
this machine has a new wi-fi chip that
should
work great for this it also has the 11th
gen evo processor that
hopefully will make this a much smoother
process so
i am going to hit finalize and we'll see
what happens okay
you can see it downloading all these
images it goes on to a part of your hard
drive that you can specify
and it is placing them into
the right space in the map comp for it
to work it's honestly
really amazing
oh are we done we're done wow that was
insanely quick again i this video is
sponsored by intel i know like i've done
this so many times
that was very fast that was buttery
smooth
again i sort of feel like why why have i
been like relying on these
insanely beefy expensive machines when i
pitch this idea of like i'm gonna do my
map workflow
that usually i do on a big monster
machine
i was sort of like can this little
laptop handle that and it 100
can it can handle it better than i
thought so i'm very impressed with the
11th gen
evo processor from intel and again
that's a totally candid
thing to say right now like i'm actually
reacting to
how well it's doing you can do all sorts
of stuff to style this up
color correct luts whatever you want but
this is the basic heart
of my mapping workflow let's get this
thing rendered out
and see what it finally looks like now
render times are really important
for video people because they can make
or break your day
if you have really long render times
with these animations
you don't want to render very often and
so you end up just guessing and sort of
doing everything in the after effects
and then doing one big render and just
like
hoping that it works when you have
faster render times it allows you to
output sort of a draft and say like i
think this is pretty close to good
you bring it in to premiere you time it
up and then
if it's wrong or if there's mistakes
like there always are you just go back
and you fix them and you render out a
new one and it's like no drama
it's not like you're committing to three
hours of waiting
instead it happens very quickly so
here's the remaining time
as it digests this it's going from what
was 57 minutes
and it is just tanking by the second
this is real time right now what you're
seeing it turns out if i go into the log
that that took encoding time 6 minutes
and 33 seconds
to render that big beast that's awesome
so this was a real
experiment i hadn't actually used this
laptop to do this workflow until
right here in front of you all and i'm
incredibly impressed with
the performance this is a small little
laptop
it fits in something that is a little
bigger than a
tablet i mean look at this and yet i was
able to do
my start to finish map workflow which is
fairly processor intensive
on this thing and it held up just fine
while i had multiple applications open
i had the screen recording software open
all at the same time
the thing that makes this whole process
run so smoothly
is the 11th gen evo processor from intel
this chip is a huge leap forward for
intel and for
all processors on the market it uses ai
to actually
reduce noise in a really smart way so
you have to worry about background noise
when you're on an important call the
chip
also helps enhance audio to make it
sound richer and better
it helps display for gaming and for
video editing no matter how you look at
it whether it's streaming
or being productive in the office or
editing maps
this chip is a powerhouse and it enables
for much faster workflows as i
just saw right before your eyes there's
a link in my description where you can
learn more about
the devices that have the intel 11th gen
processor
and you can learn more about just intel
evo overall click that link and help
support this channel but
it's also a great place to go learn more
about this really cool fast amazing
processor
the first batch of these amazing
processors
inside laptops are hitting the shelves
this holiday season and
if you are someone who's looking for an
upgrade in your workflows
this is a fantastic option thank you
intel for supporting this channel and
supporting this video
and allowing me to make a video i've
wanted to make for a long time i've
wanted to share this workflow with you
all for a long
time a lot more behind the scenes is
shared on my patreon if you want to go
over and check that out
um thank you all for being here and i
hope it's a happy holiday season for
those celebrating holidays
and happy new year and uh i'll see you
soon